qui a dit que nous avions besoin
d'Antoine Dupont pour marquer les
esprits face aux autres sélections qui
vont jouer évidemment ce weekend sauf la
Nouvelle-Zélande qui est déjà qualifiée
on connaît donc les deux premiers
qualifiés de cette poule A la France
évidemment première et puis la
Nouvelle-Zélande 2e qui a évidemment mis
une raclé à l'Italie mais la France
aussi s'en est chargé avec un très beau
score 60 à 7 alors oui on a pris 7
points on aurait pu être pour la
première fois de notre histoire sur deux
victoires consécutives sans encaisser de
point mais on a tout de même marqué h
esses les arrières ont régalé et puis je
suis avec évidemment Vincent roseron qui
va nous rejoindre dans un instant en
duplexe depuis Lyon mais mes invités en
plateau Alexandre Bertolini bonjour
Alexandre bonjour bonjour Philippe David
journaliste àass de radio animateur des
vraies voix fin connaisseur du rugby et
puis évidemment ça on l'a déjà dit
bigourdin par excellence bigourdan
bigourdan pardon j'ai j'ai failli
prendre l'accent bigourding etois passo
journaliste à l'actu du Figaro bonjour
hois et bonsoir Vincent bon on est
content voilà c'est fait c'est
l'essentiel et puis il y a la manière
c'est surtout ça ou puis je
réfléchissais je crois que ça fait
depuis 2003 qu'on a pas fait une phase
de poule aussi aussi accomplie avec que
des victoires mais surtout une victoire
face au black au premier tour il faut
quand même le rappeler résult et oui oui
le le match enfin on a coché toutes les
cases là avant un quart de finale c'est
on est c'est ce qu'il fallait faire et
on a réussi à le faire quoi donc il faut
il faut pas faut pas faut pas cacher mod
non puis il fallait pas sous-estimer
cette équipe d'Italie d'ailleurs qui
s'est un peu réveillé sur la fin de
match dans une fin de match assez
décousue mais un essai finalement bon
c'est peut-être le seul point noir au
tableau Alexandre ce petit essai en fin
de match on aurait aimé garder la la
case vierge ça aurait été magnifique
d'avoir deux victoires à zéro points
évidemment après les Italiens quand même
ont mis beaucoup d'envie ils ont réussi
à faire des longues séquences de jeux
déjà en fin de première mi-temps c'était
dur pour eux de pas marquer il une très
très belle séquence en plus on avait pas
fait de faute ils ont fait je crois au
moins 15 séquences de jeu et finalement
il y a pas Essé à cause de la faute et
la France n pas été pénalisé ou très peu
du moins alors qu'on avait encaissé 18
pénalités sur le match précédent en
tournoi de destination en février
dernier je suis avec Vincent roseron qui
était au parc OL et qui a eu la chance
de voir cette belle ambiance alors
Vincent en plus vous êtes avec car qui
ail maillot de l'équipe de France le
maillot blanc bonjour à vous deux oui
quand même parce que bon il est venu en
tant que supporter Carl bonjour bonjour
à tous ben oui il fallait quand même
supporter l'équipe de France le 16e
homme parmi les 58000 du stad de alors
il faut que vous nous parliez de de
l'ambance je pense que le micro de car é
était pas activé alors on va on va
régler ce petit problème mais en tout
cas mais ah on entendait un petit peu
bon ce qu'on disait c'est
qu'effectivement il y a eu une grosse
ambiance alors une énorme ambiance au
début une énorme ambiance à la fin entre
les deux c'était un peu plus timide on
va dire par contre on a entendu que les
Français on disit ça en début de match
que il y avait pas beaucoup on avait
quasiment pas vu l'italien depuis qu'on
était arrivé et là bah ça s'est vu dans
le stade il y avait on n pas entendu les
Italiens du tout av 58000 102
spectateurs je pense qu'il y avait 58000
supportes français et 102 italiens ça
c'est c'est assez impressionnant
d'ailleurs on a l'impression que les
Italiens avaient pressenté que leur
équipe était pas au niveau parce qu'en
fait c'est c'est un peu ça l'équipe de
France a évidemment très bien joué quand
elle est concentré comme elle l'a été là
c'est vrai qu'elle est assez dure à
jouer mais la réalité c'est que l'Italie
n'était absolument pas au niveau ils é
en avant sur même sur toutes leurs
attaques bon ils ont réussi à mettre un
essai mais sinon ça terminait soit par
une pénal sera une pass dans le vide il
av il y avait vraiment un mononde
d'écart ah oui il y avait exactement un
mononde d'écart et c'est ça qui est
assez incroyable d'ailleurs c'est que on
on avait pu penser qu'avec la Racl qui
s'était pris face à la
Nouvelle-Zélande on avait pu penser
qu'avec la la Nouvelle-Zélande l'Italie
avait fait un peu l'impasse sur le match
pour se concentrer sur le match avec la
France et en fait non pas du tout c'est
c'est l'équipe d'Italie qui n'est pas au
niveau en revanche nous l'équipe de
France enfin je dis nous l'équipe de
France elle est complèt niveau
souvenez-vous ce que son ce que son ce
qu'on se disait pardon au début du mois
de septembre après la blessure de
romanamac tout le monde écrivait c'est
une catastrophe est-ce que l'équipe de
France va pouvoir se qualifier imaginez
ce qu'on a écrit quand Antoine Dupont
s'est blessé oh là là mais que peut
faire l'équipe de France Ston duup pont
vous avez vu une différence aujourd'hui
Maxime Luc j ça marchit très bien en
fait mais oui et c'est là en fait qu'on
peut dire le l'homme du match c'est
Fabien Galtier parce qu' il a réussi à
insuffler à cette équipe un qui fait que
quand des gens aussi importants dans
l'esprit des gens qu'un rom ou un
Antoine Dupont manque en fait on s'en
rend pas compte efftivement c'est vrai
queber le remplaçant naturel vous vous
avez des suppors derrière juste vous les
a juste entendu on les a pas vu à la
caméra maisber a fait un super match on
voulait justement vous entendre vous
étiez au bord du terrain qu'avez-vous
remarqué de jber est-ce qu'il vous a
vraiment
impressionné euh alors jaliber a livré
une prestation effectivement
impressionnante il est dans énormément
de bon coups dans beaucoup d'Essé c'est
lui qui est qui est le voilà le le
dynamiteur sur les sur les trou
d'attaque il y a il y a une passe au
pied magnifique je pense pour peno
justement il y a CC Ramos qui vient lui
aussi en première mi-temps Jalibert
voilà il remplace hentamac et il le
remplace très bien alors on peut lui
dire que quand il devait taper des pénal
touches il a pas été forcément très
inspiré tout le temps mais c'est si
c'est si on vaut être vraiment très très
tatillant oui si on veut vraiment voilà
mettre des points un peu un peu négatifs
mais c'est vrai que là Jalibert nous a
fait une énorme une énorme prestation
mais à l'image de de l'équipe de France
hein pour le coup c'était assez
formidable de de le voir jouer parce que
quand il joue comme ça euh il est
inspiré sur son essai c'est assez
formidable euh il arrive à à mettre ses
équipiers dans l'avancée et lui-même il
arrive à à faire les fees qui lui
permettent de passer effectivement et
même les passes des cisive il en a fait
plusieurs je crois deux ou trois ce soir
une au pied au moins une à la main
magnifique enroulée côté droit un essai
et un essai et un essai de de filou en
plus comme à son habitude est-ce que
Jalibert rassure et puis maintenant on
aura notre potentiellement notre
charnière du pont Jalibert est-ce que ça
peut marcher Philippe ah oui Dupon
jalibè par qu'il joue pas en club
ensemble on nous a vanté le cul c'est
que d pon joue ça on va en par seul
décisionnaire il y a lui il y a le
chirurgien il y a le staff médical de
l'équipe il y a le staff technique là
c'est une décision vraiment collégiale
c'est ça ça peut évidemment très bien
marcher oui Vincent bordonav justement
on vient d'en parler est-ce qu'Antoine
Dupont doit jouer je pose volontairement
la question évidemment que je connais
votre réponse mais quand on voit cette
équipe à la sur l'essentiel est-ce
est-ce qu'Antoine Dupont doit jouer et
mettre en danger sa santé sur ce match
potentiellement contre l'Afrique du Sud
Carl a dit l'essentiel tout à l'heure
l'opposition aujourd'hui était vraiment
très faible on peut qu'être déçu de de
ce qu'a proposé l'Italie et la semaine
prochaine on devrait logiquement jouer
les jouer les springbx et objectivement
ce sera autre chose et si on peut avoir
Antoine Dupont on en parlera tout à
l'heure même si j'ai du mal à croire qu'
qu'il soit remis mais bon on verra bien
mais si on doit avoir du P autant autant
l'avoir parce que en face ça va être ça
va être vraiment différent ça va envoyer
beaucoup plus fort et ça va aller
beaucoup plus vite et physiquement le
cul libère bien ses ballons mais est-ce
que physiquement il a le le le cuir pour
alleronter fa de clair 3è ligne sur le r
tout au long du match pare pour jber ça
va pas être ça va pas être le mê le même
numéro je retourne à Lyon on a vu deny
gratter beaucoup de ballon on a vu fikou
peut-être un tout petit peu en dedans il
a fait une belle relance depuis les 80 m
français pour finir dans les 22 adverse
est-ce que les centres vous ont
impressionné et les arrières de manière
générale d'ailleurs parce que c'est
plutôt un match d'arrière on
dirait oui alors c'est un match
d'arrière parce que c'est un match
offensif donc on voit les arrières qui
peuvent se mettre mettre en évidence
Biel Baret forcément Pen qui a marqué
ses essais même si j'ai quelques
petites il y a des fois il a pas
toujours tout le temps joué à l'endroit
on va dire et la paire de centre la
paire de centre a défendu surtout on les
a surtout vu descendre et ils ont été
ils ont été impressionnant moi j'ai
trouvé galfico jeentend entier non ça la
ligne d'arrière a été impressionnante
toute la première mi-temps si vous
regardez bien les essais c'est des
essais de délier c'est essais d'arrière
Ramos sur l'essai de Biel Biar il est
formidable parce que il revient à
l'intérieur pour fixer deux défenseurs
et bielbet a plus qu'à applatir c'est un
geste alttruiste qui est incroyable
parce que j'aimeant vous dire que quand
vous faites ça vous prenez le risque de
vous prendre l'italien dans les côtes ça
jamais très agréable et ben pourtant il
le fait pour pouvoir décaler Biel Barret
c'est ça qui est assez incroyable dans
dans cette équipe on on sent que c'est
vraiment on l'avait déjà dit mais il y a
une équipe ils sont tous solidaires les
uns des autres c'est exactement ce qu'on
a pas vu chez les Italiens où on avait
l'impression qu'ils étaient tous
individualistes chacun essayant de
sauver l'équipe évidemment ça ne marche
pas parce que au rugby à 15 le il faut
être solidaire et et tout le monde a été
solidaire dans cette équipe et
d'ailleurs Alexandre Bertolini on a vu
des séquences qu'on voit très rarement
dans le rugby moderne et à ce niveau-là
c'est les deux ailers du même côté
l'arrière qui vient suppler on a vu des
un super jeu des automatismes comme si
les deux semaines qu'ils avaient passé
ensemble les avaent aidé là-dessus ah
oui mais l'équipe de France là ce qui
est impressionnant c'est queon parle
beaucoup du système de jeouux irlandais
Irlandais sont capabl de faire 20
séquences en faireur là les Français on
a fait bien 4 C séquences dignes de
l'équipe d'Irlande et puis c'est aussi
ça montre aussi que les les joueurs ont
des automatises qu' sent le jeu
effectivement sur le le premier essai il
me semble qui penau et Biel Barz sont
sur la M ex et Ramos derrière juste
derrière après peno est un aier qui
Dzone très souvent donc c'est pas si
étonnant de le retrouver sur une autre
aelle mais effectivement c'est vous nous
aviez d'ailleurs rappelé à juste titre
avec humour que c'était le seul joueur à
ce niveau-là à faire tout ce qu'on
interdit dans les écoles de rugby
c'est-à-dire de naviguer à l'horizontal
mais mais c'est aussi le charme et le
French FLIR il aime bien prendre le
périphérique ben alors que
vous place de la Concorde c'était
compliqué matin le périphérique ça roule
pas trop mal ah bah ça c'est sûr bon on
prend note je prends note nous sommes
avec Romain coursier qui nous retrouve
après l'avant match et puis ce match a
évidemment beaucoup fait parler sur les
réseaux on s'ans doute vu le score oui
alors j'avais fait un petit peu essayer
de vous faire peur avant le match for
constater qu'on avait été qu'on a vite
été rassuré donc j'avais un œil sur le
match un œil sur les réseaux et je vous
propose de découvrir les les quatre
images que je retiens et que les réseaux
ont surtout retenu de cette rencontre
alors le premier le mamia de de greégory
Andr qui parlait à ses adversaires
italiens mamamia parce qu'on a vu aussi
nous un très très beau match de rugby
une démonstration des des Français et
les Italiens que j'annonçais un peu
dangereux n'ont pas existé d'ailleurs on
essaiera de deviner tout à l'heure les
notes de nous envoyés spéciaux sur place
puisque on voit Grégory aldrit qui a
encore été très solide et qui nous avait
été précieux sur les matchs précédents
ouais donc une victoire totale et si on
passe au deè visuel les internautes se
sont même laissés à penser que peut-être
on allait alors non c'est c'est c'est un
tout petit peu après alors ça c'est
c'est celui de Fabien Galtier VO Fabien
Galtier on rigole on rigole mais on est
à quatre victoires de voir un sourire
sur le visage de Fabien Galtier lui qui
est toujours impossible à la fin il a
esquissé un petit sourire mais sinon bon
vous savez que j'ai vu que la l'équipe
mentier de lunettes de Fabien Galtier
faisait faillite euh non pardon était en
rupture de stock au contraire oui ils
avaient quadruplé leur vente bon après
ils vendaient à 300 exemplaires par mois
ces lunettes mais voilà ils sont on en a
vu dans les tribunes des fans qui
mettent alors soit exactement le même
modèle soit des modèles ressemblant soit
carrément des caricatures mais ça ça
fait partie desticien j'irai vous voir
ces lunettes assez assez folle de de
Fabien Galtier alors on l'a vu
rapidement Damien penau Damien penau on
disait maintenant un essai de Vincent
clair il a dépassé Vincent
clair il est il est juste deè derrière
Serge absolument euh donc voilà on a
annoncé peut-être un triplé il a mis un
doublé voilà il rentre un petit peu plus
dans dans l'histoire de l'équipe de
France et on sait qu' qui va largement
dépasser dépasser ce record et enfin la
dernière image c'est sur nos amis
italiens alors voilà faut faut aimer un
petit peu le foot mais c'est voilà cette
tête de tirer
henrimeitalie quand ils affrontent quand
il n'affrontent pas la 50e équipe
mondiale c'est-à-dire l'Uruguay ou
la ça vient tout de suite compliqué et
petit clin d'œil vous voyez que c'était
déjà au parc OL ce ce pe je pense savoir
pourquoi il fait cette cette moue au
parc OL thieré Henry mais bon je je me
permets plus on a pas parlé d'Antoine
Dupont on était vraiment concentré sur
le match sur les réseaux c'était pareil
donc on attend de le voir en en quart de
finale mais finalement le sujet de la
semaine on l'a oublié sur ce match qui
était une démonstration totale de
l'équipe de France du rugby ce quart de
finale qui sera probablement contre
l'Afrique du Sud mais ce peut-être
également contre l'Irlande contre
l'Écosse depuis le le stade vous avez
vous avez senti qu'on était prêt à
répondre sur le plan physique Carle
oui alors il faut faire on a senti une
équipe de France très concentrée dès le
début du match ils ont pris le match par
le bon bout au bout de de minutes en
mettant le premier essai ensuite en
enchaînant on a vu une équipe vraiment
maître de son sujet qui en fait donnait
l'impression d'être déjà projeté sur les
quarts de finale et sur euh la réception
alors soit c'est l'Afrique du Sud soit
l'Irlande peut-être l'Écosse même si a
priori plutôt l'Afrique du Sud a priori
plutôt l'Afrique du Sud on la sent prête
j'ai eu un peu l'impression je sais pas
si Vincent est d'accord avec moi que sur
la fin du match il y avait certains qui
qui accusé une fatigue on a vu aldrit
avec un peu des crampes Biel Biar courit
plus aussi vite après forcémentar pourit
beaucoup moins vite à partir de la 60e
j'ai remarqué que il il a été moins
juste dans dans ce choix après il a été
tellement étinant
voà il y a quand même eu il faudrait
voir le temps de jeu effectif mais moi
j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait beaucoup de de
courses beaucoup de jeux donc
effectivement les organismes se
ressentent la différence qu' va y avoir
avec l'Afrique du Sud il y en a deux on
sait que l'équipe d'Afrique du Sud a une
moyen d'âge plus élevée que la nôtre ça
peut jouer mais ils ont une semaine de
repos supplémentaire et ça malgré tout
ça peut peser dans les organismes alors
le match d'aujourd'hui a pas été non
plus d'une cé fol les Italiens c'était
une opposition c'était pas alors c'était
pas non plus la namibi moi je me suis
dit c'est pas non plus la namibi mais au
bout d'un moment je regarde le score on
est à la 22e minute il y a 24-0 ou 21-0
ou 24-0 je sais plus et je me dis ah bon
bah en fait c'est pareil quoi c'est
encore c'est est-ce qu'on peut vraiment
tirer des enseignements d'un match comme
ça en fait là on a montré qu'on était on
avait trouvé lesb très très bon cont les
italien mais en fait c'est peut-être les
Italiens qui sont juste peut-être très
mauvais le vrai sujet il est là c'est
effectivement au tournoi des
desessinations les Italiens nous avaient
laissé une bonne
impression surtout le premier match face
à la France c'était accroché ils
auraient presque pu le gagner après
c'était des défaites assez honorables
donc on se disait ils sont au niveau bon
la réalité c'est qu'ils ne sont pas au
niveau donc la leçon c'est difficile
d'en tirer moi j'en tire quand même une
c'est que ce genre de match d'habitude
l'équipe de France les rate un peu se
déconcentre a du mal à à les aborder
parce qu'elle se dit ou là faudrait pas
que je me blesse il faut que je fe
attention je veux arriver entier face à
l'Afrique du Sud et et finalement c'est
des matchs crispant stressants parce que
on arrive pas à bien les jouer là ça n'a
pas du tout été le cas on l'a dit tout à
l'heure on l'a pris par le bon bout on
était concentré on voulait marquer ces
Italiens c'est l'impression que j'ai eu
et surtout envoyer un signal au
sud-africain on est là
et on est là pour aller jusqu'au bout
mais justement vous m'avez inspiré une
question qu'on pose sur le chat YouTube
faut-il craindre l'Afrique du Sud on
verra ce que ce qu'en pensent nos
internautes je voudrais parler de
manière plus générale voilà c'est la fin
de la phase de pool de très beaux matchs
mais évidemment des matchs un peu
décousus que retiendrez-vous de ces
phases de poule
Philippe la grande disparité de niveau
ça je crois que il suffit de regarder le
classement plus 178 plus pas prier auage
ouais c'est vrai - 218
99 on se pose la question alors est-ce
que ça vaut la peine d'avoir une équipe
comme la Namibie bon c'est bien il y
aura pas que l'Afrique il y a pas que
l'Afrique du Sud qui représente
l'Afrique par exemple l'Uruguay bon
c'est un peu mieux mais il y a quand
même une telle disparité il y a des
matchs franchement qui vu l'écart de
niveau n'ont aucun intérêt je pense
qu'on sera tous d'accord là-dessus qui
n'ont aucun intérêt mais qui sont aussi
la seule occasion pour ces pays-là de de
de briller de s'affronter de faire
visiter de faire déplacer des foules a
mais si on se posait la question pour
développer le rugby qui est quand même
un sport moins mondialisé que le
football de faire par exemple une coupe
du monde group et une coupe du monde
groupe B qui aurait lieu par exemple
tous les 4 ans sor de Coupe du Monde bis
voilà la Coupe du Monde bis où l'équipe
de qui finit les deux premières de la
Coupe du Monde B qui monterait et cetera
parce que là il y a une telle disparité
qu'on se dit ça fait un mois qu'on que
la compétition a commencé et on va
vraiment voir les choses franchement
intéressantes au bout de 5 semaines je
vous pose volontairement la question
parce que par exemple je vous la pose à
vous etois on s'attendait pas à ce
carton mais est-ce qu'on peut est-ce
qu'on peut dire qu'on est surpris en
fait après ce 60 à 7 8 essais deux
pénalités marquées une occupation alors
ce qui est très intéressant c'est
qu'habituellement les les équipes qui
dominent à ce point-là n'occupent pas le
terrain là on a à la fois occupé le
terrain fait des contres gardé le ballon
et on a gagné dans tous les secteurs de
jeu oui oui c'est vrai moi je regardais
un petit peu les statistiques puisque
vous en parlez c'est intéressant de voir
que l'Italie se sont réagustés
simplement sur les touches là ils ont
gagné 10 touches sur 12 alors qu'en
première mi-temps c'était cataclysmique
euh et en fait c'est vrai que sur tous
les autres secteurs de jeu ils ont été
ultra dominés emmêlés complètement ils
ont été dans disciplinés il y a 16
pénalités côté italien contre 6 côté
français 21 plaquages manqué contre 9
côté côté français donc donc oui oui
c'est vrai que en fait c'est assez
éloquent c'est que quand on domine tous
les secteurs de jeu au rugby ça donne
des scores comme ça oui bien sûr c'est
logique ouais et pour compléter un peu
ce qu'on disait est-ce que quelque chose
vous a rassuré avant ce match contre
l'Afrique du Sud qu'est-ce qui vous a
avant l'Afrique du Sud dans la
perspective ouais dans la perspective de
cette rencontre ou le comportement c'est
encore une fois on a pris le match par
le bambou le fait de prendre les points
en début de match de d'être sérieux
appliquer à chaque entrée dans les 22 m
de marquer en en 24 minutes on met 24
points même si l'équipe en face est
faible c'est quand même extrêmement
difficile de s'y tenir et surtout face à
une équipe faible de pas tomber dans la
facilité de pas vouloir surjouer on l'a
peut-être fait un peu en fin de match
mais quand le score était acquis mais
vraiment prendre prendre sérieusement ce
match c'est vraiment une bonne chose
donc ça ça c'est c'est plutôt un un bon
signe ça veut dire que l'équipe a
conscience du de ce qu'elle est en train
de faire et de ce qui lui reste à
accomplir pour pour pourquoi pas être
champion du monde qui vous a convaincu
tout particulièrement Alexandre quel
joueurs vous ont plu deux joueurs pour
moi ont crevé l'écran ce soir Mathieu
Jalibert parce qu'il est impliqué dans
quasiment tous les essais et de belle
manière voilà par le pied par les mains
il fait un superbe il trouve un superbe
50 5022 qui en fait un 2222 même
carrément vers la 70e et aldrit
monstrueux en fait pendant tout le match
il a fait des charges il avancé
quasiment à chaque fois donc franchement
c'est les les deux Français qui pour moi
on le plus crever l'écran ce soir ah
c'est intéressant parce qu'il y a un
joueur qui ressort statistiquement en
fait tout simplement de de cette
rencontre dont on n pas encore parlé
c'est Thomas Ramos qui est non seulement
le me le meilleur réalisateur de cette
coupe du monde mais aussi le meilleur
Réal pardon le meilleur réalisateur au
pied et le meilleur réalisateur tout
court si on inclut son essai en plus
dans cette Coupe du Monde 61 points euh
déjà il lu manque un drop pour faire un
full sur le match donc il prendre des
cours che George for parce que c'est pas
très français d'aller faire des drops
justementos vos top de ce match là vos
joueurs qui vous ont convaincu n'essayez
pas de me sortir les de mêmes ou alors
vous avez le droit à jber c'est tout non
je lu DIRIS aldrit parce que
incontournable j'ai beaucoup aimé
également penau qui met un nouveau deux
essais Ramos qui à part une pénalité à
50 m fait encore du 100 % au pied mais
un essai et MO fana qui rentre et qui
met deux essais ouais on aura un débat
ensuite sur Mo fana c'est bien il met de
d'ailleurs c'est assez drôle parce que
Ramos est allé lui-même aplatir un
ballon en tout bout en tout bout de
ligne dans l' but qu'il est allit
lui-même transformer ensite c'est bien
côté droit alors qu'il est droitier donc
on voit l'homme de caractère et vous des
joueurs qui vous ont convaincu etis bah
même règle vous n'avez pas le droit de
sortir les M ouais mais on a encore
beaucoup parlé beaucoup parler des
arrières donc pour équilibrer un peu
parler un peu de des avants moi
j'aimerais
bien tirer mon chapeau à Charles Olivon
oui euh c'était le meilleur plaqueur du
match je crois au moins à la mi-temps
parce que de toute façon il est sorti à
la 60e il fait un match défensivement
qui est juste absolument parfait il y a
très peu de plaquage manqué dans toute
l'équipe mais bon voilà lui cétait un
mur quoi
et et puis et puis voilà wy aussi a été
très bon dans dans dans le jeu à l'avant
sur les TOU dans la touche il récupéré
de touches ou en mêlé le même la
première ligne remplaçante a fait quand
même un match formidable parce que on a
continué quand même à être très dominant
dans ce secteur de jeu donc ouais non
chapeau chapeau aux avants puis
particulièrement Charles Libon ouais je
retourne à Lyon dans quel état d'esprit
avez-vous senti l'Italie revanchâ perdue
décousu elle s'est réveillée peut-être
en cours de match vous l'avez senti
comment Carl et
Vincent dépassé moi je je sais pas si
c'est vraiment un sentiment mais moi je
l'ai trouvé dépassé je pense que ils ont
effectivement voulu dès le début du
match mettre beaucoup d'intensité mais
en fait ils ont juste pas les moyens en
fait ils ont juste pas les moyens d'être
aussi d'être à niveau il y a vraiment
une ou de classes d'écart et donc on a
vu assez rapidement que ils ont été
dépités moi j'ai trouvé à la 20e minute
on a marqué trois essais en 20 minutes
et on a fermé la maison on a dit voilà
ce match il est plié en fait vous ferez
rien dans ce matchim oui je suis
complètement d'accord avec Vincent on a
senti une équipe d'Italie qui n'est pas
au niveau c'est très curieux elle était
au niveau au moment du tournoi desess
naation ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
et là dans cette Coupe du Monde bah elle
est absolument pas au niveau
euh il y a des en avant des passes qui
arrivent directement en touche il y a
une pauvreté de jeu c'estàd qu' y a
assez peu de surprise dans le dans leur
jeu et d'ailleurs ils étaient attendus
par les Français qui ont gratté un
nombre de ballons incroyabl donc à
chaque attaque italienne ça se terminait
le plus souvent par une
pénalité donc c'est c'est assez
dramatique pour eux parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'ils sont revenus des
années en arrière à une époque où on les
considéré comme une petite nation qui se
prenait à chaque fois 60 70 points et et
je suis d'accord avec Vincent c'est
assez dur pour eux mais c'est une équipe
qu'on qu'on dit jeune mais qui baisse
les bras très vite j'ai eu l'impression
un peu de retrouver alors c'est pas le
le même genre mais mais mais l'Australie
aussi qui est une équipe jeune et et qui
baissait les bras assez vite aussi dès
qu'elle est mené dès qu'elle sent qu'il
y a une impossibilité de de marquer des
essais ou de renverser la
vapeur et justement je vous Titi un
petit peu Carl on a parlé tout à l'heure
des favoris les néozélandais les
Irlandais les Sud-Africains et les
Anglais vous en pensez quoi vous avez
peur si on les si on les a en
demi
alors les Anglais effectivement vous
avez raison il faut pas les oublier
toujours s' méfierjà pour commencer les
Anglais il faut toujours s' méfier il
faut toujours s' méfier exactement ouou
c'est une règle de base en plus ils ont
un tableau facile donc eux ils arrivent
en demi-finale finalement
presque évidemment on exagère un peu
mais les doigts dans les dans les les
mains dans les poches et ils n'auront
pas eu un tableau comme nous c'estàd que
les quatre meilleures équipes du monde
qui se retrouvent en quart de finale
c'est ça peut être un atout ça peut être
aussi un inconvénient on on a souvent
coutume de dire que quand on on enchaîne
des matchs qui sont pas d'une difficulté
extrême et que voilà c'est un peu une
opposition ben on arrive sur les phases
finales et et dès qu'il y a une
opposition un peu plus dure et ben on
peut se on peut perdre le fil nous si on
arrive jusqu'à affronter les Anglais
donc dans cette demfinale on aura quand
même à notre tableau de chasse les
néozélandais potentiellement les
africain du
Sud donc on sera vraiment totalement en
confiance et et on aura marqué les
esprits comme on le disait d'ailleurs
dès le match d'ouverture voilà on
voulait marquer les esprits on l'a fait
on est premier de la poule c'était
l'objectif que Fabien Galtier s'était
fixé maintenant on s'oriente vers les
quarts de finale voilà on connaît
l'objectif de Fabien Galtier et on sait
qu'il est prêt à aller jusqu'au bout et
justement parce que cette question elle
est volontaire c'est que on parle
beaucoup de l'Afrique du Sud en disant
que c'est une finale que c'est déjà une
finale avant l'heure qu'évidemment on
retrouvera très probablement l'Irlande
ensuite en finale si si on venait à
passer mais il y a aussi tous ces matchs
ou les Blacks absolument tous ces matchs
match après match dans les dans les
rencontres éliminatoires qui sont très
sérieux et qui sont à prendre ah ben oui
mais on a fait des matchs propres là
Italie on a fait un match très propre
les Blacks c un match ouverture on avait
la pression jouer chez nous si on arrive
l'urugu on a l'impression qu'on vit
toujours une qualification directe c'est
ça on enlève l'Uruguay et puis la namibi
vu l'écart de niveau qu'il avait on a
l'impression de façon que cette équipe a
un mental en béton et que quelque part
parce que on prend un essai au bout
d'une minute contre les Blacks on prend
un essai d'entrée de jeu en 2uxème
période et où le score était loin d'être
d'être plié d'autres équipes en 2007
quand on commence mal contre l'Argentine
l'équipe s'effondre mentalement là
l'équipe je me rappelle moi j'étais au
stade on prend l'essai en coin côté
gauche les mecs il sont sous les poteaux
et ils font déjà le point et je pense
que cette équipe a un mental tellement
fort on peut se faire sortir en hancar
mais elle a un mental tellement fort que
je pense qu'elle est vraiment construite
pour aller au bout mais vraiment je
pense qu'elle est construite pour aller
au bout 54 % des internautes qui
considèrent que nous devons craindre
l'Afrique du Sud and même dire qu'il y a
46 % des gens qui pensent que non ça
fait beaucoup n' jamais perdu face à les
nation du Nord dans un match à
élimination directe oui puis il a alors
on avait on avait vu une stade tout à
l'heure Galtier avait gagné son seul
match contre l'Afrique du Sud mais sinon
le le bilan des confrontations
francearique du Sud n'est pas bon du
tout ils ont pas fait beaucoup de coupe
du monde parce qu'ils ont commencé en 95
ils sont trois fois champions du monde
et
sinon tous les équipes qui les battent
après perdent après sauf perdent le
match tout de suite après sauf sauf la
fois où les où où l'Australie devient
champion du monde expliqu par une usure
physique justement
ouais fait pour être pour être
contredite aussi c'est comme
NouvelleZélande qui avait jamais perdu
un match en face c'estafrique du Sud
c'est une équipe qui ses adversaires qui
fait du mal et qui fait qu'on a du mal à
récupérer après vous disiez Galtier
comme entraîneur ou ah oui parce que
comm avait perdu la demi-finale de 95
des conditions particulières dans des
conditions je m'en suis par alors
pararbitre du match là je lui en veux
toujours autant parce que là c'était lui
qui avait joué deine m qui avait
remplacé un Weber qui avait joué depuis
le début de la compétition l'histoire a
pris le pas sur le rugby l'histoire a
pris le pas sur le rugby ça on est bien
d'accord la météo aussi la météo
beaucoup oui en parlant de Demi mêlé
puisque on parle de Fabien Galtier je
vais lancer ce débat qu'on qu'on se pose
tous et qui est un peu le débat l'attend
depuis depuis 2 semaines Antoine Dupont
s'il est tapte faut-il le faire jouer je
vous pose la question et loi bah la
réponse à cette question en fait elle
dépend pas de de de de vous ni de moi ni
de estte ni de du luiême bah sil est
considéré comme apte c'est que prof
enfin y a une personne compétente la
seule personne compétente qui est le
médecin la personne du staff responsable
de de donner son accord qui estime que
que queantoine Dupont peut jouer donc le
seul critère il est là si cette personne
dit oui bah oui évidemment que il faut
le faire jouer et et on le voit encore
avec son Cocar mais visiblement ça ça
avance plutôt bien sil est apte ça
signifie qu'il estte donc donc oui
allons-y bien sûr parce que j'entends
filigran depuis quelques temps ce monter
cette histoire de il serait blisser
toute sa carrière il aurait du mal à s
remettre toute sa carrière s'il venait à
reprendre un coup contre contre les
boxes mais est-ce que ce n'est pas la
compétition d'une vie Alexandre à un
moment bah pour anentend du pont je
pense que la question en tout cas pour
se pose pas si s'il peut jouer il joue
après le seul truc qui peut être
préjudiciable pour l'équipe de France et
s'il est h mais qu'il a des des des
appréhensions sur sur les impacts est-ce
qu'il va être à l'aise est-ce qu'il va
jouer normalement est-ce qu'il va penser
à sa blessure en fait c'est surtout ça
la question s'il est apte c'est est-ce
qu'il va jouer à 100 % est-ce que
physiquement il sera bien bon comme
c'est une blessure au visage normalement
physiquement il sera bien en plus là il
a repris la course le vélo les
entraînement collectif mais la question
voilà c'estce qu' va être mentalement
bien dans sa peau c'estd est ce qu' va
pas craindre les sududafricains qui en
plus vont le viser parce que vous
inquiétez pas que si du point là les
colisi et du et compagnie ils vont viser
spécialement du pont et Philipe avait
d'ailleursud parce que je pense qu'il a
quand même un mental en assie justement
et que il pense à cette Coupe du Monde
depuis des années
donc d' ou voilà c'est ça mais surtout
je pense qu'il faut pas oublier juste
une sauche sur ces histoires de BL sûr
c'est que je je je suis pas sûr
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser
spontanément que le le l'Afrique du Sud
soit forcément l'équipe la plus
dangereuse pour la santé du joueurs
c'està-dire que bien sûr que c'est une
équipe qui a un physique énorme il
cognent énormément ils mettent de
l'intensité et cetera mais en fait on a
vu que il y a beaucoup de grosses
blessures qui sont faites par aussi des
petites équipes ou des équipes moins
moins fortes parce que ils maîtrisent
moins leur geste défensif et dès qu'on
va mettre un peu d'intensité de la
vitesse les mett en difficulté il
maîtriseent plus et c'est ce qui s'est
passé avec la Namibie contre Antoine
Dupont alors que Irlande Sud Afrique
c'est exactement le
contreexemple aucune blessure il y a pas
eu de blessure non moi c'est vrai que 6
octobre au soir il y a il y a 4h j'avais
pas du tout peur avant de prendre
l'Italie h moi ce qui me fait peur en
pensant à cette coupe du monde là c'est
d'imaginer les plan que pourrait
imaginer par exemple Peter Stev duutoit
pour se faire Antoine Dupont en quart de
finale alors est-ce qu'il cherche à se
faire Antoine Dupon est-ce qu'il cherche
à en demi-finale al je peux vous dire
que les Sud-Africains étant quand même
globalement des pas des poètes je pense
qu'on est d'accord dessus s'il y en a un
qui peut aller se faire l' joue
d'Antoine Dupont colisi vous l'avez dit
ou al duo nen parlons pas lui dentis sa
mâchoire s'en souvient encore lors du
dernier test match contre les boxes là
c'est ça qui me fait le plus peur par
contre je pense une chose l'arbitre du
match aura vraiment l'œil sur Dupont et
je pense que s'il y a un contrat sur lui
ça risque de sanctionner et justement
j'ai appris quelque chose tout à l'heure
peut-être que vous ne le saviez pas les
springbx pourrai jouer sans hymne et
sans drapeau pour ce ce car de finale
parce qu'ils ne sont pas encore en
conformité avec le règlement antidopage
il y a toujours ce ce petit doute autour
de l'Afrique du Sud ça a toujours existé
là-dessus mais l'Afrique du Sud ce n'est
pas qu'un défi physique Vincent c'est
aussi une équipe qui a une tactique qui
a du jeu qui a du ballon ou alors moi
j'étais au stade face à l'Irlande et ce
qui m'avait surpris en fait c'est alors
vous prenez le train et Philipe
saint-endré vous allez au stadeirlande
vous avez comment est-ce que B pour le
journal c'est comment est-ce que les
Sud-Africains se sont fait prendre dans
les par les par les zélandais et
l'incapacité après des Sud-Africains de
de créer un rugby par rapport à ça ils
ont cherché à écarter très rapidement le
ballon sans solution et les Irlandais
les ont les ont oppressé comme ça on
avait l'impression qu'ils avaient peur
d'aller au contact ce qui était allé
contre leur ADN et ce qui fait qu'ils
ont qu'ils ont déjoué ils ont pas
totalement déjoué parce que avec un
buteur a gagné le match et puis même à
la dernière minute du match ils ont ils
ont une occasion d'essai importante avec
une une touche à 5 m mais ils ont joué
un peu contre nature mais à l'époque ils
avaient pas leur numéro 10 titulaire qui
est revenu qui a joué façon Tonga qui a
fait un match assez propre qui a mis les
points au pieds et qui devrait être
titulaire face à la France pour rassurer
au pied puis qui dans la conduite du jeu
a été assez sérieux donc on va voir une
équipe d'Afrique du Sud qu'on a pas
encore vu jusqu'à maintenant qui va
peut-être réussir à trouver des
solutions des solutions en écartant mais
qui surtout va aller dans l'affrontement
parce que c'est ce qu'elle fait c'est ce
qu'elle sait faire et c'est comme ça qu'
gagne de match on retourne à Lyon avec
Carl mus et Vincent roseron et je
voulais vous écouter justement sur ce
que vous vous avez vu pour l'instant de
l'Afrique du Sud alors ce n'est pas ce
que vous avez vu ce soir mais vous avez
vu évidemment tous les matchs de la
Coupe du monde de rugby comme comme je
le sais bien notamment les gros chocs
qu'est-ce que vous avez remarqué de
cette Afrique du Sud et est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord sur le fait que à chaque
fois elle se transcende sur ces
mondiaux et ben elle se transcende oui
mais n ce qu'on a vu pour l'instant
c'est que on pensait qu'elle allait se
transcender et battre l'Irlande je me
rappelle d'ailleurs que jean-mar Gonin
nous était l'un des seuls à nous dire
attention parce que l'Irlande c'est
c'est beaucoup plus c'est plus fort en
tout cas que l'Afrique du Sud et il
avait raison comme quoi il connait bien
le rugby quand même ah ben oui ça je
remarque mais tout ça pour dire
qu'effectivement ils ont été
impressionnants dans les matchs mais
contre l'Irlande on les a vu pas
forcément se jouer à l'endroit en fait
et être voilà après avec le problème que
vous avez dit avec avec le buteur leur
numéro 10 qui est passé quand même assez
au travers de son match on peut le dire
parce qu'il leur coûte quand même pas
mal de points mais ils sont
impressionnants ça va être un énorme
match mais bon la France si elle veut
être championne du monde il faut battre
tout le monde toujours au bout d'un
moment exactement il faut battre tout le
monde il faut battre l'Afrique du Sud
moi ce qui m'impressionne l'Afrique du
Sud dans les coupes du monde c'est qu'on
sent qu'elle est en
mission c'est pas seulement le jeu de
rugby qui leur plaît on sait comment ils
jouent ils sont là pour faire mal
notamment les les avants ils font jamais
le voyage à vide c'est toujours
l'expression qu'on utilise mais il faut
les voir rentrer sur le terrain quand
ils sont encore dans les vestiaires
quand ils sont dans le couloir avant de
rentrer sur le stade vous avez le
capitaine colissi qui chante et ils
chantent tous des champs d'Afrique du
Sud on sent vraiment que cette équipe
est en mission pour pour faire le
doubler et que ça va être un obstacle
très compliqué à franchir mais mais pas
infranchissable comme vous vous l'avez
dit en plateau comme le dit Vincent
voilà il y a cette Afrique du Sud est
prenable
d'à d'abord parce que l'Irlande l'a fait
ensuite nous on l'a fait aussi c'était
pas dans le contexte de coupe du monde
mais donc il y a des failles qu'on peut
exploiter et vous pouvez compter sur
Fabien galté pour le faire et et on l'a
dit aussi c'est c'est une équipe qui est
plus vieille que nous c'est une équipe
qui est plus vieille que nous et ça et
ça ça va jouer quand on voit que on a
quand même quelques flèches on a quand
même des avants aussi des une équipe
assez jeune alors ils sont très
physiques ils tiennent longtemps mais à
voir si les défis physiques pourrai pas
même tourner à notre avantage oui alors
je me fais le porte-parole de Jean-Marc
Gonin qui est avec nous ce soir qui
était là aussi à Lyon et qui dit souvent
et c'est ce que dit Vincent l'âge est
important aussi parce que dans une
compétition comme celle-ci qui qui est
quand même malgré tout relevé qui va
entamer la semaine prochaine les matchs
les plus difficiles et bien quand vous
avez plus de 30 ans c'est plus compliqué
que quand vous avez 26 27 ans voire
comme Biel bar 20 ans comme on dit
toujours vous connaissez l'expression il
n'a plus ses jambes de 20 ans bah chez
nous bi bar les a alors que la moyenne
d' de Afrique du Sud bah c'est c'est
plus élevé ça va finir faire jouer et
l'Irlande c'est le même cas alors déjà
je vous confirme qu'avec un pack d'avant
à 950 kg ils n'auront pas fait le voyage
à vite ça c'est sûr de toute façon et
d'ailleurs oui justement le le bteur
Libo tirait tellement mal qu'ils ont
même fait revenir André poard de
l'époque qui est quand même pas dans le
jeu aujourd'hui qui revient de blessure
flamboyant pour vous on peut y aller
sans sans complexe on peut y aller c'est
du
5050 on peut y aller ils sont prenables
un les Irlandais l'ont montré de on l'a
montré comme le disait Carl c'était hors
contexte de coupe du monde mais on les a
battu trois franchement je vais regarder
les matchs de l'Afrique du Sud contre
les bonnes équipes hein je parle pas des
autres contre l'icos et contre l'Irlande
contre l'Irlande l'Irlande gagne il y a
pas grand chose à dire mais l'Irlande
est extrêmement forte mais l'Afrique du
Sud peut gagner avec un et contre
l'cosse ils ont pas fait une
démonstration de force il mett deux
essais en 5 minutes qui tubut de prie
prendre tris points contre l'Écosse ils
ont été bon en défense parce
que les Écossais mettent seulement tris
points sur une mêlée à la la 40e minute
à la fin de la première mi-temp mais il
m deux ESS à prendre 5
minut et j'ai eu l'impression moi
j'étais au stade que il y avait un peu
une gestion de la part des Écossais
parce que ils savaient ce qu'il y avait
derre ce qui ce qui arrivait derrière
eux donc c'était gagner parce que lescos
gag du Sud ilétait pas qualifié par
contre ils battent l'Irlande ils sont
qualifiés il avait une petite gestion
pour tout miser sur le dernier match
c'est l'impression que j'ai eu et c'est
pour ça que j'ai pas été impressionné
aussi à à Marseille par rapport à
sudafricain Alexandre bertelini même
constat pas de pas de complexe ù c'est
du 5050 où il y a quand même quand même
cette expérience parce qu'on parlait de
l'âche tout à l'heure avec Carlus il y a
quand même cette expérience du côté
sud-africain bah oui c'est ça là je
peut-être que physiquement ça nantage
par contre eux ils ont bon a 34 ans ou
ça reste extrêmement costaud pareil pour
leur trisème ligne en fait pareil pour
tous leurs joueurs à peu près je pense
que justement physiquement c'est plutôt
nous ils sommes en danger comme toutes
les équipes contre l'Afrique du Sud à la
fin du match contre l'Irlande les
Irlandais il reculaient sur les impacts
la Mle irlandaise commen à exploser donc
non physiquement il faon se méfie après
je trouve qu'on joue quand même mieux
rugby que les Sud-Africains c'estd que
si on arrive à mettre de la vitesse si
on arrive à créer un peu d'incertitude à
faire un match un peu débridé j'ai peur
que ça n'arrive pas mais si on arrive à
faire ça si on arrive à créer les
espaces notamment en fin de match on
joue mieux rugby que mais il va falloir
libérer voilà nos arrières et surtout
avoir les ballons et ça ça va dépendre
not peut-être dans une tradition très
française tout miser sur la fin de match
et sécuriser le début de match sur
lequel on a on a toujours du mal et il y
a une chose sur lesqueles on peut les
prendre c'est la discipline parce qu'il
jouent quand même très dur on aura quand
mmeendarbit ça dépendra de l'arbitre et
là on on jouera à domicile ouais ce sera
pas Durban ou alors là dans ces cas-là
ça vire à l'émeut
mais je pense qu'à la discipline on peut
franchement et et ils sont prenables
vraiment ils sont prenables JEE on les a
joué qu'une seule fois en Coupe du Monde
on s'en rappelle on l' tous encore en
travers de la gorge donc je pense que là
à domicile ce serait l'endroit parfait
pour une revanche avec un essai qui est
qui touche à peine la et qui est validé
à la dernière seconde abdela benazi si
tu nous regardes coucou J'espère qu'il
nous regarde et sur je salue sur youtube
il il fait peut-être partie des 61 % à
être inquiet de ce de ce match face à
l'Afrique du Sud et vous pensez que ce
pacif historique entre les nations des
matchs historiques on voit la nostalgie
de Philippe ou de d'Alexandre quand
quand ils en parlent ça peut jouer dans
dans des matchs comme ça où c'est
vraiment du match par match des joueurs
qui n'ont même pas connu ces matchs qui
les ont même pas regardé bah je trouve
que que moi le le car de niveau entre
les grandes équipes les grandes nations
du rugby a quand même beaucoup évolué
ces derniers temps par exemple en France
c'est vrai qu'il y a aussi eu
l'émergence d'une nouvelle génération
qui je pense est quand même assez assez
décomplexé par rapport à tout ça donc
ouais je je je je je crois pas forcément
au poids du passé sur ce genre de match
et je rejoins mes camarades pour dire
effectivement que l'Afrique du Sud je
vois des failles en tout cas dans le jeu
de l'Afrique du Sud j'en vois assez peu
dans le jeu irlandais et c'est vrai que
à choisir en quart de finale vraiment je
préfère largement avoir les l'Afrique du
Sud que l'Irlande je trouve que ils ont
quand même ils ont quand même été assez
orgueilleux d'une certaine manière
faland parce qu'ils ont ils ont ils ont
ils ont fait le leur leur plan de jeu
habituel mettre effectivement beaucoup
beaucoup de défis physiques mais ils ont
pas forcément voulu s'adapter en fait au
jeu de leur adversaire et en fait ça
leur a coûté beaucoup donc je pense que
ça il faut le garder en tête et essayer
peut-être de le tirer à notre avantage
et puis voilà on a parlé évidemment de
de cette de C ces troubles au niveau de
leur le jeu des arrières
l'iboc l'arrivée de poard qui moi je
pense peut aussi déstabilisante en fait
pour
le c'est pas sûr qui qui joue en 10 moi
je pense poard il peut très bien être
mis en 12 avec avec lib en 10 et je
pense que ça peut quand même beaucoup
modifier leur stratégie d'attaque enfin
je suis pas sûr que ça soit vraiment un
gros avantage pour moi ce retour de
poard mais bon on verra bien avant de
repartir à Lyon vous avez vu ces deux
équipes jouer Vincent depuis le le stade
on entend toujours un peu ce ce
raccourci l'Irlande est une équipe bien
huilée qui qui un collectif parfait qui
fait pas de faute et l'Afrique du Sud
est physique c'est pas complètement vrai
tout le temps non parce que lesand on
était enfin ont été très physique face
face au sud-africain et je pensais
là-dessus qu'ils ont qu'ils ont gagné le
match et vraiment on avait l'impression
j'étais avec Arnaud et Jean-Marc en
tribune de presse que les les
Sud-Africains avaient peur d'aller au
contact parce que peur de perdre la
balle sur sur les RCK et d'être d'être
mis à des
f 3G irlandaise et donc ils écartaient
mais sans savoir exactement ce qu'ils
devaient faire et c'est pour ça qu'ils
ont eu du mal à à créer des occasions et
à mettre en danger à mettre en danger C
cette équipe
après je pense qu'on peut on peut battre
l'Afrique du Sud et
elle a des failles on a des outils pour
le faire on l'a fait on l'a fait l'année
dernière en novembre mais toute la
question c'est être champion du monde
après et c'est de là que ça va être très
compliqué c'est réussir à se remobiliser
après gagner en demi-finale et puis
après battre une grande équipe encore en
finale et il faut un sgé ce match dans
dans dans cette dynamique et dans cette
perspective et là les choses sérieus
commencent parce qu'on a battu les
blacks et après on avait deux matchs
faciles et un dernier match on a vu sur
lequel on a déroulé là ça a pu être le
cas on a trois matchs extrêmement
difficiles qui vont qui vont s'annoncer
pour être champion du monde il fallo
être très bon à chaque fois c'est
parfait on a conclu avec les deux
équipes potentielles sur lesquelles on
pourrait tomber il y a aussi l'Écosse on
en a pas beaucoup parlé mais parce qu'il
faudrait qu'elle batte Batt l'Irlande on
va retourner à Lyon je voudrais parler
de la Coupe du Monde de manière plus
générale et euh vous demandez à Carl et
Vincent vos surprises parce qu'on a
sélectionné les nôtres vos surprises
même si c'était des défaites des des
belles équipes vous avez vu de de belles
batailles et des équipes qui vous ont
surpris dans le jeu ou dans le
résultat euh moi il y a une belle
surprise c'était le le Portugal hein euh
c'était vraiment au départ sur le papier
on se disait bah ils vont prendre 70
points voilà les valises ça va être dur
pour eux et ben finalement non euh ils
étaient accrocheurs ils développaient un
un joli jeu donc très agréable à
regarder et là on se dit voilà oui il y
a des petites équipes qui arrivent quand
même à à bien nous nous satisfaire et et
et il y a aussi les les FIDI alors on va
voir s'il confirme demain justement au
Portugal euh voilà face au Portugal mais
ils ont failli gagner face au Galois euh
on va pas parler de l'arbitrage encore
mais voilà c'était à deux doigts il
avant pr aussi faut le dire à la 118e
euh ils ont battu les les Australiens
alors certes l'Australie c'est plus le
même niveau que à l'époque de notre
jeunesse mais malgré tout ça reste
Australie hein voilà il faut il faut
arriver à les battre donc je trouve que
là il y a deux équipes qui qui sont bien
sympathiques parce qu'en plus ça elles
ouvrent elles envoient du jeu voilà et
c'est d'ailleurs peut-être on va voir la
Coupe du Monde est pas terminée mais une
des caractéristiques de cette Coupe du
Monde c'est le jeu est très ouvert on
voit des beaux essais d' liés on voit
des beaux mouvements on n'est pas dans
un jeu de fermeture et ça c'est plutôt
de bonne augur alors moi c'est pas
forcément j'avais à peu près les deux
mêmes mais du coup jeis en prends une
troisième mais c'est pas forcément une
bonne surprise mais l'Angleterre on l'a
annoncé au début de cette Coupe du monde
en grande
difficulté un peu perdu et finalement
alors ils ont pas l'adversité la plus
incroyable parce que voà alors on sait
peut-être que l'Argentine est aussi est
pas du tout au niveau aussi mais en tout
cas l'Angleterre a réussi son Paris pour
l'instant comme le pays degal d'ailleurs
qui était annoncé en perdition aussi et
qui a battu les FIDI bon comme on l'a
dit pas forcément avec les honneurs et
pas forcément de façon éclatante mais
voilà c'est deux équipes qui font quand
même respecter cette hiérarchie oui et
alors un élément important faudrait à
vérifier par rapport aux autres coupes
du monde mais l'impression qu'on a quand
même c'est que l'hémisphère Nord domine
l'hémisphère sud si vous reg quand même
les les trois nations phares de
l'hémisphère Sud ont été battu c'est la
première fois je crois dans dans
l'histoire de la Coupe du monde que sur
chaque pooule c'est une nation de
l'hémisphère Nord voilà et ça c'est pas
neutre on se souvient quand même de de
d'une époque où l'hémisphère sud
imprimait le jeu imprimait la marque
c'est c'est eux qui révolutionnaient
souvent le jeu qui avaiit une coupe du
monde d'avance et et c'était ça qui
l'équipe du Nord courait l'hémisphère
Nord courait derrière pour essayer de
rattraper ce retard et ben là non c'est
compl complètement inversé et on peut
avoir une situation où on va avoir
peut-être les les Black mais c'est même
pas sûr mais un carré avec des équipes
de l'émisphère Nord si on m'avait dit un
jour que le match qui qui m'attirerait
le plus dans cette Coupe du Monde c'est
un FIDI Portugal j'aurais pas j'aurais
pas misé un sous etis vous vouliez
réagir justement ces belles équipes ces
belles surprises de cette ououi je vouis
je voulais rebondir justement sur sur
les FIDI effectivement et concernant ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur le fait
de de rencontrer l'Angleterre finale euh
moi je trouve qu'on oublie simplement
quelque chose c'est que l'Angleterre
aussi a un quart de finale à jouer et et
et il est possible qu'elle le joue
contre les FIDI et je ne suis pas du
tout certain de mettre une pièce sur le
sur l'Angleterre en quart de finale
contre les FIDI vu vu les les matchs que
les FIDI ont sorti et vu je et là je
suis pas forcément d'accord avec ce que
mes confrères ont dit et vu le niveau
pour moi cataclysmique de l'Angleterre
sur cette Coupe du Monde oui ils ont une
P une
pouleasion
de avec les bonus et cetera mais leur
niveau de jeu est dramatique je trouve
quand on les a vu jouer contre le Japon
ou l'Argentine mais c'était mais mais
mais je sais pas donc moi alors est-ce
qu'ils vont gagner en quart de finale je
suis pas sûr en tout cas s'ils gagnent
et qu'on les rencontre en demi-finale je
veux pas être prétentieux mais
l'Angleterre ne me fait pas peur
l'Angleterre fait peur au rugby P C
l'angetre a une belle tête de France en
2000 2011 en
Nouvelle-Zélande on galère sur tous les
matchs on finit en finale à perdre un
point contre l'Angleterre on avait été
bon non ou le car contre mais demi face
au péigal compliqué heureusement qu'on
est à 15 cont merci ça moi Borton ouis
et et de de votre côté Alexandre pareil
même qu'stal et FIDI l'équipe la plus
enthousiasmante de ce Mondial alors oui
et non a par des beau essa d'éliers
tuisova c'est pas un AER mais r les
fidiens ont continue de dire c'est du
beau jeu et cetera mais justement ce qui
fait que les fidiens maintenant c'est
une équipe sérieuse c'est que c'est plus
les Flying fidians ce qui qui un petit
peu du grand n'importe quoi mais
finalement c'est très beau à regarder
c'était leur jeu depuis qu'on les a vu
80 là maintenant devant c'est plus
solide qu'avant en touche c'est moins
mauvais qu'avant ils ont un buteur qui
est à peu près correct la touche reste
un secteur ils ont c'est moyen mais
c'est moins pire qu'avant en mêl avant
c'était une vraie catastrophe les FIDI
et également pour revenir sur le match
Angleterre FIDI qu'on aura certainement
en qu faut pas oubliez que les Anglais
ont perdu à twenam en match de
préparation contre les Fiji 3022 et que
sincèrement sur ce match là les FIDI
était au-dessus sur quasiment tous les
compartiments du jeu donc les Anglais
ils auront peut-être ça en tête donc ils
auront aucun incendant psychologique sur
des filigiens qui eux au contraire vont
se dire qu'ils peuvent à nouveau battre
les enlas et d'ailleurs Carles l'a
rappelé à juste titre mais les fitg
auraient pu battre le pays de gale ils
ont mis de mémoire quatre essaiis dont
deux refusés sur les 20 dernières
minutes donc ça a été une équipe
absolument enthousiasmante on la suivra
de très près contre le Portugal je vous
donne les prochaines échéances pardon de
l'équipe de France donc dimanche
prochain le 15 on sera évidemment au
Figaro pour suivre l'avant match la
mi-temps et l'après-match avec Tibao
Gautier et ses invités et puis en
théorie la demi-finale de toute façon la
demi-finale de de ce vainqueur qui
opposera l'Afrique du Sud et et la
France et qui affrontera ensuite
l'Angleterre ou les FIDGI sera joué le
samedi 21 octobre à 21h et puis la
finale pareil le samedi juste après le
28 octobre on sera évidemment tous là
pour suivre ça je vrais juste lancer un
dernier débat avant qu'on qu'on se
laisse c'est cet article de David RA qui
m'a fait réagir coupe du monde de rugby
pourquoi il est urgent de changer de
format changer de format parce qu'il est
évidemment question de l'élargir cette
coupe du monde pour faire des poules à 6
et qu'on évite ces de semaines de
latence entre les matchs que l'équipe de
France vient de vient de subir subir pas
forcément puisque ça lui a réussi mais
vous avez vous avez parfaitement compris
l'idée c'est très long et ça suggérerait
après d'intégrer des nations qui ne sont
pas au niveau alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire pour faire monter ces nations qui
ne sont pas au niveau ou du moins faire
émerger de nouvelles nation
ouis ça a été dit tout à l'heure l'idée
d'une mondiale a et d'un mondiale B je
me souviens au début des années 2000 les
Anglais avaient proposé ça il y avait
une une volée de bois vert c'est pas ce
qui est dans les clous là y avait une
volée de bois vert entre ça mais moi ce
serait une idée qui me qui me séduirait
parce que je trouve que les car est très
important j'ai eu le papier David et il
me convint un peu sur l'idée d'un
élargissement qui permet d'avoir des
poules plus homogènes parce qu'on est
sur des poules le 4 et donc une tête de
série deux équipe moyenne et une équipe
plus mauvaise en dessous ce qui fait
qu'il y a moins de Scor fleuve il y a
qu'une seule équipe qui est susceptible
de mettre des des scores fleuv je vous
donne des pays susceptible de de nous
rejoindre Hong Kong la Russie bon la
Russie ça semble compliqué Canada
États-Unis Espagne j'ai même vu les Cook
l'pagne ça fait deux mondiaux qui
devrait jouer qui sont éliminés sur
tapis Verton et la dernière fois
honnêtement euh il s'agit d'un match
contre le Pays-Bas où il man 50-0 ils
font jouer un mec 3 minutes qui qui
devrait pas jouer mais et World rugby
les suc mondial à cause de ça euh donc
l'Espagne ça peut être comme le Portugal
hein c'est c'est une équipe assez dense
qui dans le tournoi B fait fait des
scorses intéressants avec une longue
préparation ça ça peut être intéressant
donc cette idéelà me séduit un peu des
poules en fait resserrer les poules des
poules de 4 des poules de 5 c'est trop
long il y a trop d'écart quoi donc pas
de poules de 6 des poules de 4 resserré
avec moins de moins de gros écart et
puis la possibilité pour certaines
équipes potentiellement ensuite de de
faire des montées des descentes comme
des comme des divisions Alexandre
surtout en fait pour qu'on a des un
niveau plus homogène ça se joue pas au
moment de la coupe du monde ça se joue
dans les 4 années qui qu'il y a entre
les coupes du monde parce qu'en fait
transers mais en fait on a a la
tradition la tournée d'été tournée
d'automne donc on a les les cinq grandes
équipes du Nord maintenant il y a
l'Italie en plus qui affronte historique
les trois grandes équipes du Sud
aujourd'hui à l'Argentine en plus mais
en fait on est resté bloqué ce qui est
assez logique parce qu'on a envie de se
mesurer nos rivaux qui sont dans le sud
mais du coup les petites nations
s'affronte entre elle et elle joue
jamais contre nous donc en fait si on
veut qu'il se rapproche de nous il faut
qu'on les fasse jouer plus souvent avec
nous re c'est ça en plus
ou matchibi a joué qu match voilà c'est
ça donc ils jouent jamais ils ont jamais
de rassemblement a sorti le Ken je crois
pour se qualifier ouais ou puis une
boucherie 50 à0 je crois donc en fait
est-ce que cette Coupe du Monde a plus
d'équipes c'est pas l'extension de le
domaine de la boucherie pour reprendre
c'est le risque non mais je me pose une
question si le Portugal avait affronté
l'Italie dans cette Coupe du Monde ah
c'est une très bonne question qui aurait
gagné parce que on nous aurait dit que
le Portugal claquerait deux essais à
l'Australie l'Australie qui est pas au
mieux c'est vrai mais qui est une grande
nation de rugby ils ont fait des matchs
le Portugal qui contre le Payal a été
très intéressant
absolument mat moi je suis pas certain
je suis match nul contre la Georgie
avecéné la gagne à la dernière minut une
faute grossière qui donne à l'essé à
7énal ouais et je suis pas certain que
l'Italie de ce soir aurait battu le
Portugal qui a joué le pays de gale
ouais surtout pas convaincu he ouais
mais vous voyez c'est ce genre de débat
qu'on va continuer toute la soirée et
toute la nuit je vous remercie tous les
quatre d'avoir passé cette soirée avec
nous et puis merci à tous ceux qui nous
ont aidé à préparer cette émission
Virginie le trionire à la programmation
Vincent rou à la rédaction en chef Sacha
Baudu à l'édition romain et François au
son et à la réalisation et puis
évidemment mes invités Alexandre
Philippe etois et Vincent et puis je
voudrais juste faire un petit coucou
s'il est encore là à Vincent roseron et
et à Carl mus qui nous ont fait vivre ce
match ce post match qui était au stade
voilà merci encore d'avoir été avec nous
et de nous avoir livré vos analyses et
puis on se retrouve dimanche prochain
contre l'Afrique du Sud l'Irlande ou
l'Écosse et on aura un œil avisé sur le
match de demain soir irlande-écosse au
Stade de France 21h merci
beaucoup